getting to grips with her first bicycle
every Sunday morning ramoth Hamid joins
her friends at her local cycling club
for the 11-year old this is a totally
new and sometimes daunting experience
initially I dragged the bike along with
my feet then I slowly learned how to
control it I love the fact I can ride
now I wish I could cycle every day with
my friends as it makes me feel really
good
well that talent they're both masada
it's quite rare to see women on bicycles
in Pakistan as many thing it is vulgar
as they have to straddle a seat but
these attitudes are also part of a wider
patriarchal culture society doesn't feel
right about girls cycling out in the
streets it doesn't usually happen here
but it's common abroad it doesn't feel
right but it's okay
they're only riding around locally what
can we say those parents who allow their
daughters to ride on bicycles should
women socializing in public is still
viewed as a threat to public morality it
is to counter these norms that a group
of women set up the Lyari Girls cafe
that also organizes bike rides for girls
come on Jamal a woman but at the start
we were harassed and some boys even
tried to kick us off our bikes it was
tough but we won't stop it's our mission
to empower these girls and introduce
them to sports which is also very
important the girls live here in Li re
not only a poor and conservative
neighborhood of Karachi but one that has
been marred by violence for decades
things are better now
although the streets are still dangerous
in some parts especially for women so
the sight of them exercising in public
has caused quite a stir
but attitudes are slowly changing Ramis
parents were reluctant to allow her to
join the cycling club at first but soon
changed their mind hey comet Channing my
family and my in-laws both said that
it's not a good thing and I should just
stop her it's a problem in our society
that if a girl goes out in public for
anything safer work or even cycling
people talk bad about her but my husband
and I think differently so what if she's
a girl she should go out and also
progress see the only topic when the
cycling club began a year ago they
started with only eight girls now there
are over 30 members and all are
determined to keep pedaling their way
towards a fairer and more equal future
in Pakistan more on this topic we're
joined by Farzana bari she's a pakistani
feminist and human rights activist and
she joins us from Islamabad
Prasanna thanks for talking with us this
morning first of all International
Women's Day is drawing attention to the
challenges that women face around the
world what are the main challenges
confronting women in Pakistan I think
the first and foremost challenge in
Pakistan is that women are not
recognized as independent human being
you know women have seen in relation to
others like as a somebody's wife or
mother and sister or so but women in
their own right as an independent human
being you know and therefore I think
this issue of not only recognition but
also women's representations for example
in decision-making bodies whether it is
at the the in the public sphere or
private sphere I think that's the
struggle which women in Pakistan are
going through that they want to be
recognized as an independent human being
you know in their own rights projects
like the bike club for girls that we saw
in our report they're a little project
in Karachi is that sign that something
is changing in Pakistan yes something is
changing in Pakistan particularly
younger women are trying to play in
their space although the space we had
in 60s and 70s for example when I was
growing up there was no issue if I was
bicycling but I think slowly there is a
there was a radicalization in Pakistan
particularly during 80s and I think that
we had this small now our trend of
radicalization is on the rise and
women's space is shrinking day by day
but I think particularly the young
feminists and women from you know
working women they are claiming the
space and they are pushing the
boundaries marches are taking place
today all over the world to honor women
and demand that the rights be respected
are people marching in Pakistan - yes I
think I feel that this year even that
you know preparation for it
International Women's days March is much
more at a bigger I think is going to
take this in a bigger scale
women are also coming together like
women as are the March for example
initiated by women Democratic Front but
it is going to be it has been organized
in coalition with the networks off like
NGOs and other you know working women's
network and it is being like organized
almost in all big cities in Pakistan so
yes I think this year I see the this
celebration or commemoration of Women's
International Day is going to be at a
much bigger scale much bigger level all
around the country
Rosanna Bari a Pakistani feminist and
human rights activist thank you very
much